[MUSIC PLAYING]
KELLY MARSHALL: But we would
love to know a little bit more
about you before we get into
RX's story, so talk to us
a little bit about where
was Sam before RXBAR
and how did you land at RXBAR?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So I grew up in the western
suburbs outside Chicago.
Ever since I was a
kid, I loved business.
And when I graduated
from college,
the best way to pursue
that was through finance.
And so I started my career in
finance doing health care M&A,
and pretty quickly realized I
didn't want to stay in finance.
It just wasn't--
I had no edge.
I wasn't going to be
the best finance person.
It just wasn't the
right path for me.
I learned that very fast.
And so I called a guy
who'd been a mentor for me,
and he had found a home
security business to buy.
And it was a consumer business,
direct to consumer home
security concept,
basically 100% digital.
And so it was an
interesting concept
and that was my first
foray into operating
and really entrepreneurship.
So we bought a very small
company west of Topeka
in Kansas, rebuilt it as a
completely new concept called
LiveWatch Home Security, and had
a great, successful run there.
Ultimately, that company was
acquired by a strategic buyer.
And I thought a
lot of the concepts
we had used at LiveWatch,
I thought actually
could apply well
to a food company.
And Jared and Peter, who we'll
talk about, had founded RXBAR.
And so that's how the
conversation started
and that's how I
ended up at RXBAR,
was sort of talking through the
connection between how we built
a home security business
and how it could actually
apply to a food company.
So I think we'll
get into that, but--
KELLY MARSHALL:
Yeah, absolutely.
So I don't know if
all of you know this,
but RXBAR is more
than just bars, right?
So they have grown to be
an international company.
They operate in the United
States, Canada, and the UK.
So they've got the bars,
they've got nut butters,
and they also have
the RX kid line.
So if you haven't
had an opportunity,
you probably do on your
chairs, but they're also
in a store near you.
So, all right.
So what do you think?
Could I be in sales?
SAM MCBRIDE: You're doing great.
KELLY MARSHALL: So you
have this prior experience,
and they start talking to you.
So what was your first job?
As an HR person, did you
have a job description
that you agreed to or--
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So our first office was
actually down the street,
and this was before
you all were here.
So this is like maybe 10 blocks
west of here, which I think
is technically
West Loop, but it's
not like the cool part of West
Loop that you guys work in.
And we worked out
of our warehouse
so we were surrounded
by pallets.
It was Peter, who
is our CEO, Jared,
who is Peter's co-founder,
myself, and Jessie Stewart.
And Jessie is also a
childhood friend of ours,
so all four of us have known
each other since grade school.
And at that point,
everyone's in sales
because the only
thing you're doing
is thinking about how you
get the brand out there
and how you get the
product in people's hands.
Everyone's sort of in marketing,
but marketing is really
not a conceptual thing.
It's really fundamentally
to drive sales.
It's like really cause and
effect kind of marketing,
not like brand building stuff.
And then Peter and
Jared had a lot
of familiarity with the supply
chain manufacturing process
because they built the
business manufacturing by hand.
So long answer is not really.
When there were four
of us, everyone kind of
did a bit of everything and
the business was very simple.
It was make bars and sell bars.
And that was basically it.
And then like in between
there, hopefully there's
enough cash to buy enough
raw materials to make
more bars the next time.
But that was essentially
the business,
and it was really not much more
complex than that at the time.
KELLY MARSHALL: So jack
of all trades probably
would've been at the top
of that job description?
SAM MCBRIDE: Probably everyone's
job description back then,
yeah.
KELLY MARSHALL: So you talked
about it started by hand.
Say a little bit more about
the innovation by hand part.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah, yeah.
So Peter's family is
in the food space,
and so he had deep
intimacy with the food
just growing up with a
family in the food business.
And basically what
Jared and Peter
saw in the market was that
there were clean bars,
but there really weren't
clean protein bars.
So the question that they
asked and the problem that they
solved with RXBAR
was, why isn't there
a protein bar that's clean?
And so the original way
that they manufactured
was taking a 5-quart mixer
like you have at your house,
putting in dates, at the
time, it was half a fig,
some egg white, and then
depending on the flavor,
you would have almonds
and blueberries
or you might have
coconut or some cacao.
All the chocolate flavors
used to be called cacao,
but no one knew
what cacao was so we
started calling them chocolate.
People would be like,
what's "kuh-koe-uh?"
We were like, all right.
This is not good.
But so they manufactured
them by hand.
Hand pressed them
into bar molds,
put them into
resealable pouches,
and then initially
drove them around
to CrossFit gyms in the area.
And then later, in the
next version the business,
they actually shipped some
product around the country
to different CrossFit gyms
mostly and then direct
to people's homes.
But the business was
built in its infancy
on two guys hand forming with
their thumbs protein bars.
KELLY MARSHALL: Wow.
That brings some interesting
pictures to light.
And probably some trial and
error happened in that kitchen?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yes, definitely.
KELLY MARSHALL: If that
kitchen could talk.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
Mrs. Rahal was--
I still call her Mrs.
Rahal because she
was the first person
fired from the company.
She was putting front
labels on both sides.
But yeah, a lot of
trial and error.
KELLY MARSHALL: You had some
HR early on, it sounds like.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah, exactly.
KELLY MARSHALL: Very good.
Well it's fun to see
how it all started.
So you know, one of
the biggest things
that Peter Rahal,
so the founder,
talked about in an
article recently
with Forbes was just all
the naysayers and all
the challenges and
people, all the doubters.
So you know, you
are just coming off
of a pretty successful
experience prior to joining RX.
Do you recall kind of like,
how did you guys get over
those hurdles?
How did you get over that
hurdle to join the organization?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So it's actually become--
so my first experience
operating is in home security.
And the home security
company was like 50 miles,
maybe 100 miles west
of Topeka in Kansas.
So how many people have been 100
miles west of Topeka in Kansas?
Yeah, OK, so not a ton.
So this small, you
know, rural area.
And I still
remember, my wife was
working for a private
equity firm at the time,
and I would go to
their meetings.
And you know, private equity
people are pretty cool.
And so I would tell
them like, yeah, I
sell home security
systems from Topeka.
And they were just like,
wow, like who is this loser?
But it actually has
become a filter for me.
So I think any kind of early
stage company or product,
if it's not met with enough
people that don't get it
or if it's not like kind
of uncomfortable for you
and a little bit embarrassing
to explain what you're doing,
probably too many people
are already doing it.
And so when I think
about LiveWatch,
that was for sure true,
and the same thing
was true in a different
way for RXBAR, where
number one, the first
reaction is like,
why do we need another bar?
There's hundreds of bars.
And then from there, once
you explain like, hey, there
actually is a product position
here, then it's like, OK,
how are you can
actually execute?
None of you are from food.
You don't know
what you're doing.
And then when it came
to the packaging,
this is my favorite one.
So the packaging is what
we're famous for now.
You know, we win awards for it.
People are like, oh my god,
the packaging is genius.
And when we first did the--
who's eaten them in
the old packaging?
There's probably like a couple.
Yeah, OK.
KELLY MARSHALL: The
resealable ones, right?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
Well the resealable
were the first,
and there's a second version.
But if you look them up online,
they're not good looking.
And it was only because we
were marketing to a very, very
specific niche that it worked.
But when we made that change, we
showed people the new packaging
that you see today.
Everyone was like, this is the
worst thing I've ever seen.
They were like,
this is terrible.
We even showed it
to retail buyers
who we were ultimately
going to have to sell to.
And they were like,
we will never--
like, I can't be
clear about this.
We will not take your product
if it looks like this.
So it's just another
example where
we were so confident
in it because we
were so close to the consumer.
And we were selling
direct to consumer.
We were taking their phone
calls, answering their e-mails
when they had problems.
We were so tightly
connected to the consumer
that we knew that
it would resonate.
We knew it would work.
So even in the face of
people literally saying
like, I'll never buy
this product from you,
we still did it.
But I think it goes to
the theme of like people
who are doubters, sometimes that
can actually be a good signal.
KELLY MARSHALL:
And so how did you
win the hearts
and minds of them,
of the retailers that
eventually, clearly,
have bought some of your bars?
SAM MCBRIDE: So
ultimately, the retailers
are servicing their customers.
And so if there's
enough customer demand,
they're going to respond to it.
And we knew our
customers intimately.
And when we think
of customers, we
think of individual
people, not retailers.
I mean, retailers are our
customers too, but really,
the consumer.
And so the consumer responded
so well to the product.
And our customers who
were buying online
or who were posting on
Instagram, they loved it.
You could just see that
they were so excited
about the packaging, and so
eventually, the retailers
came around.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah.
You know, numbers talk, right?
Let's be honest.
So I mean, you kind of
hit the nail on the head.
It was a really saturated
market when you guys decided,
we're going to take
up this charge.
So like, did you ever imagine
you'd be this successful?
And what really-- the
packaging is great,
but what really distinguishes
the RXBAR from you name it?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So I think one of the key
distinguishing-- number
one, the product does
solve a clear problem.
So Peter and Jared's
insight was right,
that there wasn't
a protein bar that
was as clean as what
you'd get out of
like, say, a LARABAR, which just
doesn't have as much protein
but is a clean product.
So the first thing
is the product,
just it totally
solved a problem.
And we always talk
about it now, if you're
solving a problem
with a product,
you're running downhill.
You know, that is
like essential.
But then the big
differentiating factor for us
was that we spent about two
and a half years exclusively
selling to CrossFit gyms,
other fitness studios,
and then direct to consumer.
And so we understood
our product's value
from the perspective
of our customers
so intimately that we
had a great instinct
for the business,
and it was because we
were talking directly to
the people consuming it.
So if you think about it, if
you go a traditional route
and you sell in the
grocery stores first,
you're selling to a
distributor and then
a grocery store
and then someone's
walking in and eating it.
And most people, like who's ever
called an 800 number for a food
product that you bought
in the grocery store?
Like nobody, no one does that,
so you don't get any feedback.
And so we were so
tight with the consumer
that we understood
it intimately.
And so the big
differentiating factor
was when we went into
the traditional channels,
in grocery, we
went in a way that
was speaking to our
consumers really
clearly, the packaging
being the biggest form.
So I think that was the
biggest differentiating factor
in the business.
We thought it'd be
successful, but we never
really like set out, what
are our expectations?
But if you'd asked us
four years ago, for sure,
this is faster and
more successful
than we would have bet
back then for sure.
KELLY MARSHALL: So
one last question
related to the early
days, and then we're
going to move
forward a little bit
to kind of where
you guys are today
and what's happened in
the last year or so.
If you can, what are some
of your earliest just
funny memories of
like, oh my gosh,
I can't believe
we made that work,
or oh my god, I can't
believe I had to do this,
but we pulled it off?
Just what are some good
memories from the early days?
SAM MCBRIDE: So my
favorite-- and this
speaks a lot to the
company culture,
but it's just also a good story.
So we went to Expo West
for our first time in 2015,
and Expo West is the biggest
food convention in the country.
Every natural brand that you've
ever heard of is at Expo West.
I think 150,000 people were
there last year, so it's
like the Super Bowl of food.
And so we're still
in the old packaging.
We have no retail
distribution at this point
because we're a
dot.com business,
and we're really thought
of as a CrossFit brand
by anybody who's heard of it.
But most people just
hadn't heard of it,
so we're like not
on the map at all.
And we've rented this 10 by
10 space, and like KIND bar
next to us has
like a city block,
and there's like fireworks
going off and roller coasters,
and we're just like, oh my god.
Like, we are massively
outgunned here.
So Peter and I flew
in the day before,
and we didn't even have a booth.
So we had reserved the space,
but we're just running so fast
at that time that we
didn't even have time
to like design
and build a booth.
And so we had like a
backdrop that had the bars,
and like a little, you know,
slogan or something like that.
And we were like, all right.
We'll fly into LA a day ahead
and we'll build this booth.
Like we'll go to Home
Depot and wherever else.
And so we built a booth
and it was honestly decent.
Like you wouldn't be
super impressed by it,
but it wasn't terrible.
And so the night before,
we all huddled up.
And so it was Jessie, Jared,
Peter, and I at the time.
And we huddled up, and
we were like, all right.
We don't really have
that great of a booth.
Nobody knows us.
We have no retail distribution
to speak of, but if we--
we had walked the show
the night before, another
show that was adjacent.
And we were like, if
we bring good energy
and we engage people
and we share our product
and we share the
story and we're like
genuinely good to be
around, it won't really
matter what the booth
looks like, right?
And one of the
key things-- and I
see Megan smiling because she
knows what I'm about to say.
So one of the key things
that we figured out
was that when you walk up
to people's booths, often,
they will look at your badge,
figure out whether or not
you're worth talking to,
and then either talk to you
or kind of like dismiss you.
And we were like, god,
that's like so rude.
You know, they're just sizing
me up based on my title
and company and whatever.
And so we came up with
this rule that morning.
We were like, all right.
We are not badge fucking people.
Because like that's
what's happening.
They're badge fucking you,
and they decide whether or not
they want to spend
time with you.
And so we're like, this is like
a hard rule for the company,
like no badge fucking.
And so we have this
little sign that
hangs in our booths today
that says no badge fucking
with a little red thing.
Am I allowed to swear here?
This whole recording
might be just thrown out.
KELLY MARSHALL: Equal
opportunity to anyone
who came to your booth
is what I'm hearing.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah, exactly.
But so that was something like,
number one, the scrappiness
and entrepreneurial
spirit to just like
go out there and build this
thing the day before, but then
also to think about like, OK.
Who are we engaging and what's
the right way to engage them,
and remembering that every
single person that we met
was a potential consumer.
Even if they weren't
Kroger's buyer,
they might be somebody
who goes into a Kroger
and buys bars who,
ultimately, is actually
more important than
Kroger's buyer anyways.
So that's one of
the early stories
that I think we still
think a lot about.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah.
That's fabulous Yeah.
I love it.
So, you know,
humble roots, right?
That's a theme here
and that's just
what's so inspiring
about this story,
is you guys were literally in
the trenches figuring it out.
You were learning as fast
as you were doing, right?
And clearly some good
learnings on that first trip.
So let's talk a little bit
more about the product.
So we've talked about
the packaging is amazing.
It filled a need.
So how have you guys kind
of evolved the product
when you think about
innovation, specifically
the bar and kind of what's
continuing to distinguish it
in the market?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah,
so the bar itself
is very close to the
original formula.
The big difference is
we've replaced half a fig
with cashews.
And the reason for that was
we kept hearing from consumers
that, hey, it
sticks to my teeth.
And so one of the
ways to help mitigate
that was to replace
fig with cashew.
But in a larger sense, we're
always looking at like,
how do we make the product
incrementally better,
so we're always
improving the bar.
Even if the ingredient
isn't changing,
we're just thinking
a lot about like how
do we make those small
incremental improvements.
And then when we think
about new innovation,
like the nut butters
that were on your chairs,
we really think about
it from the same lens
that we looked at the
bar category, which
is, is there a crowded category
where there is an opportunity
add value, so adding protein
into a category that maybe
doesn't have that
offering, or is there
an opportunity to add
simplicity and simplify
a category with a
product like RXBAR that
was significantly simpler
from an ingredient standpoint.
KELLY MARSHALL: Got it.
And so congratulations
on the nut butter launch.
It's been great and I'm pretty
sure our family might keep it
in business.
But they're delicious, so
please, everyone try them.
They're fantastic.
You know, the market
is changing, consumers
are changing, so
there's a lot of GMO
this, non-this, non-that,
different diet trends, vegan,
Keto, all of those things.
How are you guys thinking about
that and what kind of approach
are you taking?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah,
and especially-- so
our early adopters, many
of them were either doing
a Whole30, which is a
type of nutritional reset,
maybe they're a paleo eater,
so a lot of our early adopters,
they are cutting edge
eaters in the sense
that they'll experiment
with different diets
and figure out what
works well for them.
So we definitely
pay attention to it.
Instagram's an amazing
source of information
when it comes to that.
Like you can just
see trends and you
can see how people talk about
it, so we watch it closely.
But we don't overreact
to any trend because--
and the packaging
actually reflects that.
So it would have been very
easy for us to put paleo
on the front so that we would
attract paleo consumers,
or put gluten free on
the front so we'd attract
gluten free consumers, but we
kept the labeling extremely
simple because we wanted to
appeal to people who wanted
clean, simple ingredients.
And our thought was, if
you're a paleo consumer
or a gluten free
consumer, you're
going to see the ingredients
and know that you can eat it.
We don't really need to
spell that out for you.
And so we keep an eye on trends.
We don't overreact
to them, but we
think generally, the
trend that's here to stay
and will grow significantly
is really just clean eating
and whole food
ingredients, really trying
to simplify the
foods that people
are putting in their bodies.
So we'll always be
tied to whole foods,
clean simple ingredients.
And sometimes we'll
hit a trend, but it
won't be intentional to
just like chase a trend.
KELLY MARSHALL: Sure, yeah.
And talk to us a
little bit-- how
do you guys come up
with the flavors, right?
So pumpkin spice is the fall
one, but talk to us a lot
about the innovation.
And you guys have stayed pretty
consistent on the core bar
flavors, so what
brings about, maybe
let's introduce another
flavor into the market?
SAM MCBRIDE: So honestly,
it's a lot of just
internal experimentation.
So we have a team
at our office here
in Chicago that experiments
with different flavors.
And one rule that has been
a firm rule since day one
is that it has to taste good.
So we're not going to
look at the category
and say, hey, we're
missing X, Y, or Z flavor,
and just say we have to
formulate that flavor
and you have to get
it out by March.
It's really driven
by the product.
And because our roots are
digital and direct to consumer
and direct to independent
CrossFit gyms,
we don't necessarily
build flavors
for a retailer's
reset schedule, which
is a very common thing
in big food companies.
Once the food is ready
and it tastes great
and we feel really
good about the product,
we can launch it on our website
before we go into a retailer.
So the process is really
designed around the food.
And when something tastes great
that we feel awesome about,
then we'll launch it.
KELLY MARSHALL: Got it.
What are some favorite
flavors in the audience?
Who's a chocolate
sea salt person?
Peanut butter chocolate?
That's me.
Who's loving the new
blueberry in the [INAUDIBLE]??
Yeah.
What is the number one seller?
SAM MCBRIDE: Chocolate sea salt.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah.
Sweet and salty
gets us every time.
So it's been a busy
past year for you guys.
I don't know if anybody's
aware, we probably are,
but you guys had a pretty
successful 2017, being acquired
by Kellogg's for a mere $600
million so congratulations
on that.
That's something to very proud
of, but that's a big change.
So my previous career
was in CPG as well
and, you know, I've gone
through kind of the acquisition
experience.
And so I would just love to hear
your perspective, and you know,
Peter and Jared.
What were you guys
thinking when you
thought about kind of going
public and joining a bigger
brand?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
The biggest thing that
we were thinking about
was values alignment, so we
learned early in the business--
so because we'd all known each
other, we grew up together,
it's kind of like you never
sit down with your family
and write out your core
values, you know I mean?
They just sort of like are
what they are and everybody
knows them.
And that was how it was
in the early days for us
because we'd all grown up
together, so it was easy.
But once we got to a
certain number of people,
we realized we really
needed to be really
thoughtful about core values
and make sure that we all
knew what they were, we were
communicated consistently,
we were hiring around it, we
were firing because of it,
promoting all that stuff.
And so the same thing
was true when we
went through the sale process.
Anybody that we spoke with, we
were really clear about what
our values were and that
we felt like alignment
was really important.
And then Kellogg had had
experience with Kashi
where they bought
Kashi and ended up
integrating Kashi, sort
of taking Kashi back out
of Kellogg and making
it a standalone.
And through that
process, they were
really committed to keeping
RXBAR as a standalone business.
So that was a huge thing for
us as we talked to Kellogg,
is they had had experience that
they didn't want to repeat,
and so they were really
thoughtful about communicating
with us about maintaining
RXBAR's autonomy and ability
to operate as a
standalone business.
So that was a huge thing.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah.
And so something
that strikes me,
you know, you guys
are so principal
and it's about what
you guys really think
and listening to your consumers.
You know, becoming part of
a much larger organization
is really impactful actually
to the consumer potentially, so
how did you think about talking
to your consumers as well
as your employees
who kind of started
with this entrepreneurial,
loved what they were doing,
and like significant
change probably for them
even though you'd
remained a standalone?
How did you guys think
about that communication?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So it had to be--
so it's a tricky thing because
you get a lot of advice
on it, and competing advice.
But ultimately,
it came down to we
had to be-- so your
values and your principles
are tested not when
things are easy and good,
but when there's a
tricky situation.
And so we leaned on those
and we built a culture
that's extremely transparent.
We talk about
authenticity a lot,
and so it would have been
totally against our culture
had like, you know, we showed
up on a Thursday morning
and been like, hey,
Kellogg has bought us.
The announcement's
happening tomorrow.
And so we brought the team
along from the earliest
stages so everybody-- at that
time, we were 100 people or so.
Everybody knew
about the process.
We would update people on where
the process was at generally,
without disclosing
anything confidential.
But we were really
transparent with the team,
I think way more transparent
than a typical company is
during an acquisition process.
And so that was the biggest
thing, was being transparent.
And then we did the same
thing with our customers.
So we thought the
exact same thing.
We were like, you know,
we're proud of this.
We think it was good
for the business.
We think it was the
right thing to do.
And so why wouldn't we tell
the most important stakeholder
in the business, which is
that people that eat the bars?
And so we sent out an
email that was so on brand
for us that was
just super direct,
and I think the subject
line was, Kellogg bought us,
or something like that.
But it was just
super direct, and we
weren't going to like,
hope nobody heard
about it or something
like that, because we
were really proud of it.
And so the whole process was
really driven by thinking,
how can we be totally
transparent and authentic?
And overall, it was
received really well.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah.
That level of
transparency, I think
that's something that we share
similarly here at Google.
And so just curious, you
know, what were you guys
looking for in deciding to
join a larger organization,
assuming things are on scale
which we're experiencing
as we continue to grow, but what
has Kellogg brought for you?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So I mean, they're a 100
plus year old global--
Kellogg was really one of
the first food companies
to be a global company.
And so they have
international expertise
that's second to
none and in basically
every corner of the world.
And so they brought
a global perspective
that would have been really
hard to build internally, really
hard to build as fast as
we needed to build it.
So that's one of
the biggest things,
is they just bring an incredible
global perspective for us.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah.
Yeah, absolutely.
And curious, you
know, what do you
think you have brought
to them, right?
Because you guys have
had some great successes
and some learnings at that.
A smaller group
is able to kind of
fail fast and, again,
former CPG, it's
slower to respond to things.
So what do you think they're
benefiting from having you
under their wings?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So Kellogg is used to
operating in a world where
the brands are huge and
they're fully distributed
and they're global.
And most of our time,
until the last 12 months
or so, we were a
small challenger brand
that was coming into a set, that
was operated incredibly lean,
and went to market
in a unique way.
And so when they're thinking
about new brand launches,
there's a lot that they're able
to glean from us because that's
really where we're
really strong.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah.
And from what we've heard,
it's gone really well.
Right?
Which isn't always the case.
Sometimes, you know, you're
kind of the case study,
the poster child for
successful acquisitions.
So you know, they've
kind of allowed
you to remain kind of your
own operating business,
if you will.
But what else is going well,
or what is a day like at RXBAR
today, maybe
different or similarly
than it was a year ago?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So it's different than
it was a year ago,
but not because of Kellogg.
So Kellogg has been amazing
in that they've really
done everything that
they said they would
throughout the
acquisition process,
but the company has grown.
So the company is
twice as big as it
was when the
acquisition happened
which was about a year ago.
And so the day to day has
changed just because we're
a bigger organization.
I mean, it's nothing like you
all, but we have 250 people.
We're now sold in
international markets.
There are more people on the
team that have specialties
than we've ever had before.
So the business has changed,
but it's all just sort of-- it
would have changed
whether or not
we were acquired by Kellogg.
KELLY MARSHALL: Got it.
And what are some challenges
that you guys are maybe
dealing with today that
having greater scale
has presented that, you
know, two years ago, it
wasn't something maybe
even on your radar?
SAM MCBRIDE: Challenges
we're dealing
with today because of scale?
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah, just
as you continue to grow.
It's not always easy.
SAM MCBRIDE: Well we have more
customer stakeholders now.
So we're sold in
almost every retailer.
We're sold in Canada,
the UK, and working
on more and more GOs.
And so the business just
takes more coordination.
Like if you picture when there
were four of us in a warehouse,
it's just easy because you know
what everybody else is doing.
And essentially, there
are company shared goals
and there's four people, and
so each of those four people
have one top
priority for the day,
let's say, so you have four
organizational top priorities.
So once you have 250 people,
now, even though everybody's
marching in the same direction,
there are more stakeholders
and more people
working on a project.
So I think the biggest
change has been coordination
internally.
KELLY MARSHALL:
And so how has it
changed how you've had to
lead, or the leadership
has had to lead the
business differently?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So in the early stage--
I always think of
it as a continuum,
and there's like
execution and strategy.
And this isn't perfect,
but in the early days,
you're like 95
execution, 5 strategy.
You know at a high level
where you're going,
but really all you're
doing is executing.
And then as the
business grows, you
have to spend more time on
strategy because now you're
driving a much larger
organization towards a goal.
And so that, we've
definitely shifted a bit more
and added more strategic
long-term thinking,
but I'd say that's probably
the biggest difference.
KELLY MARSHALL:
Yeah, interesting.
It's a different muscle, right?
I mean, you're growing
in your leadership,
the whole team, so
I'm sure it's been
a pretty interesting journey.
Hopefully you have some
good HR around you.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
And as a leader, it's
different because you
go from being able
to touch everything
to almost being able to have
your hands on nothing almost.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah.
You have to let go and delegate.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
And so you have to be able to
trust your team, empower them,
but you just can't--
you literally can't
micromanage it.
And so I think that's
one of the hardest things
as a leader is making
that transition from,
hey, I get to put my head
down and just go do stuff.
And doing stuff gives you
instant gratification.
Like you go and sell it
into a Costco region,
and they say yes, and you're
like, yes, like in the moment.
But the other side of
it, you get very little
instant gratification and
it's almost all setting things
in place to
hopefully make things
work six or 12 months from now.
And so that's a very
different thing.
And especially just
that feedback loop
is a little harder
to digest honestly,
because the instant
gratification feels good.
KELLY MARSHALL:
Yeah, absolutely.
So while we're on the topic
of just people and talent,
we'll come back
a little bit more
to the product and the business.
You know, my understanding
is that you guys
take your talent
and the development
very seriously, which is
something that's really
important to us at Google.
But I hear you've got some
interesting maybe people,
talent development
practices at RX
that would be interesting for
the group, I think, to hear,
in terms of, while we're on the
topic, a bit of transparency.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
Yeah.
So as I sort of
briefly mentioned
before, we got to a stage
where we could feel like,
wow, we've outgrown
our clothes basically.
And a lot of it was
people who had previously
been working seamlessly,
all of a sudden it was like,
man, this just doesn't feel
as smooth as it once did.
And so we brought in a
coach who started out
as an executive coach, and
the first thing that she did
was had us take a tool called
DiSC, which is kind of a comm--
and I see some nods so maybe you
guys have tried it or used it.
You guys use it?
KELLY MARSHALL:
Personality profile.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
KELLY MARSHALL: Some groups.
SAM MCBRIDE: And like a lot
of it is personality profile,
but a lot of it's tied
in to communication.
And so that was the
first thing that
helped us take a step back
and sort of look at the team
and the way it was
built and say, OK.
I can see where we might have
some gaps because we have
all drivers and no people
who are like detail oriented
and slower, right?
And that's not
exactly what we had,
but you could start to like
see where the holes were
in the organization.
And so that was the first
time that we used it,
but what that
started was we focus
a lot on the individual
employee, what they're
naturally really good
at, how they show up,
and what are the
areas that they need
to be aware of as derailers.
And so as a part
of that process,
we want people to be vulnerable
because you sort of have to be
in order to really understand
what's-- because you know,
the way you work and like you
as a human is being put on this
piece of paper and it's
kind of like unnerving.
And so you have to build
an environment where people
are vulnerable enough to receive
that openly and then act on it,
and then hopefully share it
and be transparent enough
with it to use it and let
the other people around
them use it.
And so one of the ways that
we were talking about it--
and one of the things
is that everybody
who has a direct report has
one on ones weekly with them.
And we sort of felt like
one on ones and reviews
are probably just not going
as well as they should be,
and part of it is probably
because new managers are
uncomfortable giving
tough feedback,
probably people are not
that good at receiving it,
but there's this
feedback loop problem.
And so Peter and I were like,
all right, what if we just
do my annual review in
front of the whole company
at an all hands meeting?
Because there couldn't be a
more public way to do my review.
And also, so in addition to
me just like putting my money
where my mouth is and say like,
hey, you should be open to this
and you should share
your flaws and be
open with the team
about them, it
also showed them that like
I have legitimate weaknesses
and like legitimate areas
where I had to improve.
And so it was really good,
and it was amazing afterwards.
So many people came up and
were like, that was amazing.
And we actually had one guy in
the room who was from Kellogg,
and he was like,
that was ridiculous.
He's like, you would
never have seen
that like at a bigger company.
And so it was really,
really effective
in getting the idea that
like being vulnerable is OK
and everybody's got pretty
decent sized weaknesses.
KELLY MARSHALL: So who's
signing up for that here,
next time around?
Anyone?
No?
OK, we'll come back to that.
So let's switch back a little
bit more to kind of the market
and what's going
on in the industry.
So technology is
changing things,
so let's talk a little bit about
e-commerce, club, traditional.
How are you guys going to
market a little bit differently
and how are you thinking
about some of those things?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah, so
our route to market
was different so we
started with e-comm
and we started with
building relationships
direct to CrossFit gyms
and things like that.
And so that's something
that's very hard to go
backwards and do,
because no matter
what, Costco is going to be a
bigger revenue driver than one
CrossFit gym.
And so it's really
hard for companies
to go the opposite way.
Once they've already built
their Kroger business and Costco
business and Walmart
business, I haven't
seen any companies go backwards
and decide like, hey, we
need to invest in individual
points of distribution
that we're going to
ship directly to.
So the big thing is that,
foundationally, we're
built completely, call
it upside down compared
to what a normal food
company has built.
And so we still think
about distribution
in that same way, which is,
first is the person that's
going to eat it.
So we think about
them before we think
about the retailer
that ultimately
gets them the product.
And so when we roll
out new products,
we will go bottoms up.
So we'll sell it in our
direct to consumer first.
We'll sell to our CrossFit
gyms and other independents.
And we'll bring it
out to retail quicker
than we did for the
bars, but we still
think about it in
the sense that it
has to service the
person eating it.
It doesn't do anybody any
good to do a massive launch
in all retailers until you
know that the product's going
to be well received.
It just doesn't make sense.
So we still think
about it that way.
KELLY MARSHALL:
Yeah, absolutely.
It makes good sense.
So let's bring it home, and
what's coming down the line?
What does the future look like?
You guys, I think one of
things you're best at is like,
you see the white
space before any of us
as consumers are probably even
thinking there's a problem.
And so you've really led
some incredible trends.
So what's on the
whiteboard at the office
and ideas we should
be thinking about?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So when we think about
the future, the way
we think about it
is that the way
that we went to
market and the way
that we built the
business, which is also
a bit unique compared
to most food companies
where finance, supply chain,
and sales have an equal seat
at the table with marketing.
Traditionally in
big food, marketing
is really general management
in most food companies.
But so we think that
there's opportunity
to leverage the team
that we've built
and bring in more
brands that are leading
edge in their category and where
we think the consumer is going.
And so by this time next
year, if we execute well,
the team that's leading
RXBAR should also
be managing other brands too.
KELLY MARSHALL: OK.
You can't tell us anymore
about that, can you?
Just thought I'd ask.
And so as you think
about that, you know,
the company is going
to continue to grow.
How do you make sure you
keep the center of gravity
in terms of values?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
I think it's the hardest
thing to do, honestly.
So scaling a business,
the hardest thing to do
is to keep the ways of
working and the values
and the principles, keeping
them true and alive.
So we try to do it in a bunch of
different ways, the onboarding
process.
When you join RXBAR, you spend
two weeks in customer service.
And the rationale there is when
we were back at the old office,
everybody was in
customer service
because we all had
phones at our desk,
and when someone called the 800
number, everybody's phone rang.
And we had a rule
that it was one ring.
It had to be answered
before that second ring.
And you would see
people all the time
running across the room
to go pick up a phone.
If we had an all hands
meeting, which was, you know,
six people, somebody
was like next
to the door to man the phones.
And so we try to keep a
lot of that stuff relevant,
like the badge
example that I gave.
Just in case they have
to cut out that segment,
you guys know what
I'm talking about.
You know, stuff like that.
So we try to keep a lot of those
principles relevant in the way
that we work, the way people
are brought into the company.
But it's really tricky.
It's really hard.
KELLY MARSHALL: Yeah, I know.
Absolutely.
And it's one of those
things, you just
have to continue
to refresh them.
And you have to continue
to practice them as leaders
and ultimately, it's every
employee's accountability
to live them.
So in five years, five,
10, what kind of company
is RXBAR going to be?
SAM MCBRIDE: So it will be
a global multi-brand company
that--
the hope is is that-- actually,
we learned a lot from you all.
So OKRs was a
concept that I know
you guys are familiar with.
And so when we think about
running the business, that's
one of the big
differentiators over time
is how you actually work.
It might be the
differentiator over time.
And so I think, to
the market, RXBAR
will be multi-brand and global.
But internally, I
think what you'll
see is some best
operating practices that
are pretty common in tech
that are not as widely adopted
in food.
So if you were on
the inside, you
would see that we
work in a way that's
very different from a
traditional big food company.
KELLY MARSHALL: Awesome.
Good.
Well, I think we'd love to
open the floor up to you all.
Hopefully there's
some questions.
We will have a mic that is
going to be passed around,
so you get two seconds
for a breather.
And so if anyone
has a question--
Megan, we've got one
here in this row.
AUDIENCE: Is there
any kind of story
around that amazing
Ice-T commercial?
KELLY MARSHALL: Maybe
explain what it is.
SAM MCBRIDE: Oh, yeah.
OK, so the Ice-T commercial.
So Ice-T, if you
haven't seen him,
if you're on
Instagram or Facebook,
it looks like you're
just looking at a bar.
And then he kind of comes out
of it and says something witty
and then goes back in the bar.
It's like a little door.
The idea was that we
wanted the product
to be front and center,
which it is in those ads.
And then we wanted to take the
same approach to advertising
that we've taken
to the packaging.
So we say no BS on the
packaging and that's
kind of a filter for the company
in terms of the way we work.
But then also, when we
think about advertising,
we wanted it to be true to
that, and you know, sort
of shine some light
on some things.
Like I don't know if you've seen
the AdWords that we're running
with you guys, but it's
like, you searched paleo,
here's an RXBAR bar ad.
And just things
like that where it's
like very sort of in your face
in the way that we're doing it.
KELLY MARSHALL: Matter of fact.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So obviously,
Google is a big data company.
Can you talk about how you
guys use data internally
to move forward,
develop strategies,
think about product innovation?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
So the data that we
try really hard--
and this is one of the more
challenging things with scale,
that we try really hard to
build muscles internally
for is actually subjective data.
So one of the biggest
learnings that we ever had
was when we would
sample with customers,
and they would eat the
product, and depending
on how they would react,
that would tell us a lot.
And so one of the times that
I remember most vividly,
Peter and I were demoing
at a condo association
meeting in River North.
And a condo association
meeting is like six people,
so that tells you like we
would literally demo anywhere.
But we were like trying
different lines on people,
you know.
We'd say like, real food protein
bar, whole food protein bar,
no added sugar, or
gluten free, whatever.
And you could just
watch people react
or not react to these lines.
And so now, we get
more of that data
than ever because we have
field teams out interacting
with people all the time.
So that's one of the
things that we're
focused on really figuring out,
how do we scale that behavior?
Because ultimately, our
products need to fill a void
and we need to
communicate in a way
that, the people who eat
them, that it resonates with.
And so that's one form of data.
And then we also do
a pretty good job
of managing our
independent business,
so like the CrossFit
gyms, using data
in terms of what do we
expect them to be selling,
are they buying, are they
using the right flavors?
So it's not like super
complicated data,
but it's one of the ways
that we manage a business
with thousands of
distribution points.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I heard that you were
responsible for getting
into Whole Foods.
Could you tell a
little bit about that?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
I wouldn't say I was--
I mean, you know,
the product is really
responsible for most of it.
But so the process
for Whole Foods,
when we were selling
into Whole Foods,
it was broken into
regions and so
we would have to call
on every single region.
So there's SoCal,
there's NorCal,
there's PacNorthwest,
Rocky Mountain, Texas,
on and on and on,
and so you'd have
to sell into each one of
those Whole Foods regions.
And so our journey within Whole
Foods went region to region
and it started in the Northeast.
A guy named John
Lawson saw the product
and understood it
immediately, and was like,
hey, we've got to have
you in our region.
And then there
were some regions--
there was one region
that wouldn't take us
because it said no BS.
And she said, I have too
many evangelical Christians
in my territory.
I can't take you.
And we were like, I
think they'll be fine,
but you know your customer
better than we do.
So Whole Foods was really like a
region by region kind of thing.
And now, they do a lot
more national buying,
but back then, it was
a regional sell in.
And so you'd have to go
in and pitch to the buyer,
and then six months later,
they would reset it.
AUDIENCE: So we know
which products you have,
and I'm sure you can't
really speak to the products
that are coming soon, but what
are some examples of products
that you guys have
brainstormed in the past that
didn't make it, and why
did they not make it?
KELLY MARSHALL: Or flavors.
SAM MCBRIDE: So from
a flavor standpoint,
we've tried almost
everything under the sun.
Products that we-- I mean,
so once the bar took off--
so the packaging changed,
and once we went into retail,
the business like
shot up really fast.
And so honestly, during that
period, we brainstormed things,
but we really were
like, we have to execute
this, which was no
small feat because we
have to make a physical thing.
Like, you know, we have
to make lots of bars
and they need to be consistent.
So during that phase, we
were honestly just like,
let's just make sure we
execute the adult bar.
And then the kid's
bar was an opportunity
that came after that, but there
wasn't a lot in that time frame
that we said no to, because
we were just totally focused
on executing the core business.
There is always stuff
that we're playing with.
I wouldn't say anything's
ever like shut down,
because it's all-- maybe there's
like an ingredient barrier.
So for us, because
our promise is
on the front of the label
in terms of the ingredients
that we use, we have a
relatively constrained
innovation map because we
can't add just anything
to the product, right?
So to some extent,
we have to innovate
within a relatively narrow
set of ingredient options.
So everything that's
in the market right now
is what we've gotten close
to, like we made it work
once we know it's going to go.
But anything else, we're sort
of like playing with still.
Sorry if that was super vague.
AUDIENCE: I'm so curious.
In the beginning, you said
you were at a home security
company, but you felt that
there were so many learnings you
could take to a food company.
What were those?
SAM MCBRIDE: So LiveWatch
Home Security was the name
of the company, and it's now
been rebranded as Brink's.
So the company that owns
Brink's, the armored trucks
and the security is
who bought LiveWatch.
So the way that we
built LiveWatch was, at
the time, very, very cutting
edge for that industry.
So the way the home
security industry works
is the business is
constrained by the installer.
So if you think about
a traditional business
where an installer has
to go out to the home
and put up the sensors
and everything,
that business is constrained
by the number of homes
that that installer
can go to in a day.
So like the growth
of the business
is literally like number
of installers times homes
they can get to, and
that's all they can do.
And so we took the approach
of taking the installer out
of the business.
And so what we did
was we built a--
in those days, it was
called a DIY system,
but we wouldn't call it that
because DIY scares people away.
It was just a home
security system
that you would install yourself.
And so immediately, we were
a national direct to consumer
home security business
instead of having
to buy trucks and hire
installers and all that stuff.
And the way that
we went to market
was we used digital, so 95% of
our spend was through Google.
And then we managed our
pipeline with email,
and we did it in
a way that was--
So we had an inside
sales team that
would call and help people
customize their system,
close the sale, and then we had
a team that would ship it out.
So what we tried to do was
to scale that inside sales
team through email, because
we thought, you know,
if you're a great home
security sales rep on our team,
what are you doing well?
And ultimately, it came
down to you're following up
with relevant information
at the right time,
and usually through email
because most people don't want
a call from a sales person
at 9:00 AM on a Thursday
because they're working.
And so we used email, and it
was plain text, personalized,
and what it was meant to do
was to scale that inside sales
team.
And so we had done two things
that were pretty innovative.
One, we took the
installer out so we
could scale fast right away.
And then the second thing was we
lowered our cost of acquisition
because our conversion
rate, the number
of leads that a
salesperson could
work themselves
was 10X what you'd
be able to without this great
email engine that we'd built.
And so I thought, if you guys
are selling in the CrossFit
space, there's actually
a good opportunity
to use digital
marketing and email
and put an inside
sales team in it,
and we could scale the business
through that channel instead
of going right into retail.
And scaling in
those channels meant
that we were more
profitable than we would
have been going
through distribution,
our cash flow was much better.
Because if you go
through a distributor,
you're usually net 30,
net 45, net 60 terms,
whereas someone paying
with a credit card
is paying you net
negative 1 basically.
And so we talked about
it, and we thought,
boy, some of those
same principles
could be applied here
to this food company.
And what was
exciting about it was
the same thing at LiveWatch,
which was no one else
was doing it.
And so we could--
everybody, oh, why
another bar, right?
It's such a crowded category.
Well actually, we
weren't in the category.
We were just selling
to CrossFit gyms
and there were no
bars at CrossFit gyms.
Or we were selling
straight to your home
and we were reaching
you through a paid ad
or on Instagram
through influencers.
And we couldn't use influencers
in the home security business
because no one wants to post
about their home security
system, but we could use
influencers really effectively
for food.
And we were on the total cutting
edge of influencer marketing.
No one was doing it
when we were doing it.
So those were kind
of the core things
that we could translate
from home security to food.
I'll tell you guys
a funny story.
My wife is in the audience.
And so our influencer
strategy was literally
like me laying in bed direct
messaging people on Instagram.
And so in our space,
there's a lot of like,
it's health and foodies, right?
And so there's a lot of
like really good looking
fit women in this space.
So I'm like laying in
bed next to my wife DMing
all these like really good
looking fitness women,
and she's like,
what are you doing?
KELLY MARSHALL: All right.
We probably have time for one or
two really quick ones, I think.
One.
AUDIENCE: This is kind
of a specific question,
but could you talk about
dates for a second?
I remember that's kind
of like my first question
that I had when I
first tried an RXBAR
and never really
grew up with dates.
And specifically, I wonder
what the supply chain
looked like for
dates, especially
as you grew in scale,
like whether you
had an impact on the date
industry or date farmers?
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
KELLY MARSHALL: It's had
an impact on them too.
SAM MCBRIDE: Yeah.
We're talking about
date, the fruit, right?
So in the US,
basically 100% of dates
are grown in the Coachella
valley in Southern California.
And actually one of the
things, while we were scaling,
this is in 2017 I think, we
used to just call date farmers
and say, hey, we need
a truckload of dates
or whatever it was.
And then we picked
up the phone and we
tried to place our
order, and they
were like, that's too many.
We don't have-- and we
were like, oh, my god.
We've outgrown the
US date supply.
And that was a huge
eye opener for us.
Like we'd never thought--
we'd honestly just never
even really thought about it.
And so one of the things that
we knew but hit home for us,
is that dates are an
agricultural product that
is harvested.
So it's not like eggs where
hens lay eggs all the time.
Dates get harvested once a
year, and you either have enough
dates for the year or you don't.
And so when that
happened, we realized
there's no more
supply in the US,
so we just had to
broaden the way that we
look at that raw material.
And so we expanded our
sourcing beyond the US,
and we've had to be really
thoughtful about where they
come from and who we work with.
But the date industry
in particular
was one where we like first
felt a pinch on raw materials.
KELLY MARSHALL: Awesome.
Well, I think that's
our time today.
So thank you so much,
everyone, for being here.
SAM MCBRIDE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]